- I think, you know, "Hey, pissflaps!"
I think "Hey, pissflaps" is quite good.
- Hi, I'm Gena,
I'm here with Emma Mackey
from "Sex Education"
and these are her Netflix Nine.
Okay, Emma, so the time has finally come.
- Yes.
- Season two, you know,
- it's here, it's ready.
All the people that were
asking us where is season two,
it's here, I have Maeve
herself right here with me.
So starting off light,
what are you most proud
of about this season
and what's one of your favorite
storylines this time around?
- That's a lovely question.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- I am most proud of the, it's
a double thing, triple thing,
but it's the idea of sisterhood,
we kind of broach the idea of sisterhood
in a much deeper way.
- Yeah.
- In a really beautiful, nuanced, warm way
and I love Maeve's relationship with Amy,
their friendship is just beautiful
and I love her relationship
with Miss Sands,
Miss Sands, I keep saying this,
but she's become like the
Miss Honey to Maeve's Matilda,
do you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- She's kind of that
protective figure at school
and then obviously Maeve and her Mum
and how that's sort of
a whole complicated rigmarole to navigate.
But yeah, the idea of sisterhood
is something I'm really,
really proud of this season,
I think it works really well.
- So a lot of people, you know,
obviously be shipping Otis
and Maeve, but for me,
my favorite relationship in the series
is definitely Maeve and Amy,
I think you guys are so
hilarious together as actors.
I've heard from your other cast members
that Amy on set is very funny,
what is it like for you working together
and getting to portray
such a beautiful friendship
that I think is a really good example
to like supporting each other like women
and things like that.
- Yeah, I completely agree
and that's the thing I said
at the end of season one,
when everyone was like,
oh, is it Maeve and
Jackson, Maeve and Otis?
I was like what about Maeve and Amy?
- Yeah, right, they're the core.
- This is what's actually happening.
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
I think their friendship like you say
is a really positive one,
'cause they're not comparing each other,
there's no competition,
there's no judgment
and they sort of just
coexist beautifully together,
even when they are so
diametrically opposed,
is that a word, diametrically?
- Yeah, I'm gonna say it
is, if you say it is, it is.
- Diametrically opposed, okay.
- Was that also mirrored
off set too for both of you?
- Yeah, well yeah, and this is the thing
and also this season,
because obviously we have a
little bit more confidence,
we know a little bit
more what we're doing,
we got to sort of inject mine
and Amy's real life humor
and kind of chemistry into our characters,
which is so joyous and so lovely,
I mean, we just do accents
and silly voices all the time
and sing and do all these
moments together and it's lovely.
- Is it true that the
"Ta'ra, pet" is something
that they added in afterwards
or was that part of--
- That was like an ad lib that we did.
- I love it.
- Yeah, yeah,
that was us, yeah.
- Ta'ra, lad.
- See you later, pet.
- Alright, so let's go
delve a little bit more
into storylines, so I mean,
Maeve's storylines this
season are gut wrenching.
For those emotional scenes,
particularly I'm talking like the end,
how hard was it to get
into that space emotionally
and to do those scenes,
where you sort of have to be
more vulnerable on screen?
- I don't know if difficult is the word,
luckily I had the
incredible Anne-Marie Duff,
who was just there and existing
and being incredible at what she does
and so I just had to sort of
react to what she was doing,
so a lot of the work was done for me
and the writing obviously
does a lot of the work for me as well,
it was just beautifully written
and it made a lot of sense
and it was so, like you say,
gut wrenching is how I felt,
I felt like it was a lot that
day, those couple of days
that we filmed those scenes were a lot,
but in the best way, actors love that,
we love a bit of melodrama.
- Yeah, yeah.
I was like okay, Emma, you'd better act,
you'd better act, Emma, give me the tears,
give me the little mouth tremble.
- Give me the tears, I wanna see you cry.
I wanna see you cry.
So yeah, but I really
enjoyed it and the writing
and Anne-Marie Duff were
a massive, massive help
as you can imagine,
- Yeah, yeah.
- in that situation.
- So in my Netflix Nine
interview with Ncuti,
who plays Eric in "Sex Education,"
I asked him who his favorite
"Sex Education" character was
and he said it was a tie.
- Can I just have it between
Jackson, Amy and Maeve?
- So if you had to choose
your favorite character
from the show other than
Maeve, who would it be?
- Well, again it would
have to be a tie situation.
- Oh, yeah.
- I would say Eric, Amy and Jackson.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, this time round,
Amy and Jackson's
storylines are so important
and so well thought through
and presented at least in this season
and I think that it's gonna start
some interesting conversations,
so yeah, I just wanna hug them both
and just kind of look
after them, you know.
- So a very famous line
of Maeve's from season one
is her response to Jackson,
when he asks what she's into
and she replies, "Complex
female characters."
- Yeah.
- What is your thing then?
- Complex female characters.
What a great one liner.
- What a great one liner.
- Yeah.
- Who is your favorite
complex female character
from TV or film?
- Ooh.
- And why?
- Oh, my God!
I think recently it's been
"Fleabag," hasn't it really?
- [Gena] Ooh, good, that
is such a good answer.
- Thank you, she's had a massive impact
I think generally on the industry
and the way her work is received
and the way she is received
as a writer and a director
and an actor extraordinaire
is really empowering
and she's such a good
example and a role model,
'cause "Fleabag" was so provocative
and so direct and so
frank and funny and dark
and had this like real kind
of visceral nature to it
and I think that her character is,
I don't think we've ever
seen anything like it before,
which is why it's so revolutionary
is that she's just not hiding
anything, which I love,
so I think she's a very brave person.
- Yes.
- Very brave.
- So I'm going to read you some
of Maeve's phrases/insults,
- Okay.
- And I want you to rank them,
- Oh, my God, this is
great, this is great.
- I want you to rank them from best to,
I'm not gonna say worst,
'cause none of them are bad,
so best to like least best.
Number one, "Fuck off, snowflake!"
- Yeah, that's very good.
- Two, "Hey, pissflaps!"
- That's good.
- Yeah, it's a good one.
- That is the one, yeah.
- Number three.
- "Hey, Pissflaps!"
- "Alright, dickhead?"
- Yeah.
- That's classic, I think.
- That is classic Maeve.
- Classic Maeve.
- That is classic Maeve,
vintage.
- Four,
"What's up, dickstain?"
- "What's up, dickstain?"
- Yeah.
- I remember that scene.
- Yeah, yeah.
All top tier.
- Oh, my God!
It's all the top tier stuff.
Fuck off, I'm gonna say,
"Fuck off, snowflake!"
- "Fuck off, snowflake!"
Yeah.
- Number one.
- Because just chronologically
it makes sense.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then we're gonna go with,
I think, you know, "Hey, Pissflaps!"
I think "Hey, Pissflaps" is quite good.
- Yeah, alright.
- I think "Pissflaps"
and then "Dickstain,"
- Okay.
- And then, "What's up,"
because the "Dickhead" thing is just,
that's how I just call Otis all the time.
- Yeah, right.
- So it's great,
but it's just the more mellow one, yeah.
- Okay, that was a good ranking.
- Thank you, yeah.
- That was good,
you did really well.
- I was so focused,
I didn't look at you, I was like this.
- No, I know, you were really,
I appreciate how seriously you took it.
Let's go with some more broader
sort of existentially kind of questions.
- Oh, okay.
- Just to get to know you
a little bit more, you know,
Emma Mackey, you know.
- Who is she?
- Not Maeve but Emma, who are you, right?
If you could be famous
for any other thing,
no matter how random, what would it be?
- Like I'm gonna make up a job,
but I'd wanna be like a humanitarian
international lawyer kind of thing,
like I'd wanna be known
for actually helping people
and actually doing something
practical in the world.
- [Gena] Oh, that's really nice.
- I wanna be the protector.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The protector of the people.
- That's much nicer than Maeve.
- And if not, it would be
like a dancer or something,
I love the idea of dancing, you know,
that'd be cool as well, wouldn't it?
- Mine is like I wanna
sell lipsticks, anyway.
- That's lovely as well.
- Yeah,
but it's not like I wanna save people,
it's like actually I don't.
- Well, yeah, I mean,
actually I don't, sorry.
- I just want lipstick for myself.
Okay, if you were invited
to a fancy celeb dinner
and could be sat next to any
celebrity of your choosing.
- Living?
- No, they could be dead.
- Okay.
- It would be slightly weirder,
- No, they could be dead.
- but they could be dead,
- Okay.
- I could do that.
Who would it be?
- Okay, hm, right now it'd
be Michelle Obama, I reckon,
someone like Michelle Obama,
you would have the best evening.
I would just kind of
listen to her and be like,
tell me about yourself.
- Yeah.
- I wouldn't whisper it,
tell me about yourself.
- Yeah.
- That's creepy, sorry, Michelle Obama.
- While she's about to tuck into like.
- It's like tell me about yourself.
I'm such a little creep, I didn't know.
- As someone who's both
French and English,
I'd like you to settle a debate
between Netflix UK and Netflix France.
- Oh, are you gonna do the tou doum thing?
- Yeah.
(light melodic music)
- Fucking hell.
- Right.
- Okay, this is tough, this is tough.
- Yeah, this is tough, this is tough.
- Can you tell me how the
English, what is the English one?
- This is the French one, tou doum,
this is the English one.
- Yeah.
- Da dum, right.
- Da dum.
- Da da, this is like,
to me it's like duh duh, duh, duh,
but that's a D like, duh.
- See, I'm sorry, but I'm--
(French National Anthem)
- Are you really doing this?
- I'm team tou doum.
But I mean, you've written it,
but it is like a T.
- It's like, go on.
- It is actually really hard,
'cause it is a machine making
this noise and I can't do it,
but I hear a tou doum, tou doum.
- Really, you're a T?
- It's a T.
- Because I'm hearing like, duh duh.
- It's between a T and a
D, you hear what, duh duh?
That's not the Netflix one, duh duh.
- Can you imagine if they just changed it
to me being like duh duh.
- But I think truthfully I'm
somewhere between the two,
but I think it leans
more toward the tou doum.
Tou doum, yeah.
- You're perfect in every way to me, Emma.
You are fantastic, honestly.
- Thank you.
- Our time sadly is up together.
- Oh, God.
- But it's been fantastic speaking to you.
Season two is fantastic and
it was great watching you
and I hope to see more
of you in the future,
but for now these were your Netflix Nine.
- Thank you, thanks.
(laughing)
- I was worried for a
second, I don't know.
- I was really worried, like
how long's she gonna be?
Seeing your sort of thinking face.
- You were doing so well.
I think it's shit.
I've fucked this already.
- It's good, I got you.
- It's a good answer,
thank you so much.
(light melodic music)